hello and welcome and we can just get
right into this because you know what we
smash your pass candace ellen yeah
she'll get the willy wonka smash yeah
she will get she'll get yeah an eyelid
we are going to cover today we obviously
add smash 2. that's why it's so painful
because you're just like you're so sexy
why did you have to do do georgia like
this because you're just
you just need to just say sweet things
you have to cover the george floyd trial
conclusion which is that derek chauvin
is guilty on all counts and i have to
appreciate people that were trying to
create a pressure campaign for me on
twitter saying i wonder what candace is
going to say even republicans agreed
that this was the right call i don't
care
who agrees that this was the right i
don't care if it's a republican i don't
care if it's a democrat i don't care if
it's a white person i don't care if it's
a black person i am not so much of an
intellectual coward that because the mob
decides something because the lie about
george floyd and the way that he lived
his life has become so big
that we just have to now accept it as
the truth and believe me this is a lie
nancy pelosi yesterday
said quote thank you george floyd for
sacrificing your life for justice
she also said quote that his name will
always be synonymous with justice
george floyd's name will always be
synonymous with justice you have got to
be kidding me don't tell me doesn't
matter it does matter this is the most
important part that he is now becoming
synonymous with justice let me remind
you guys i've done it before right when
the media was spinning all the lies and
the media first came out and they said
oh george floyd was just getting his
life together he moved to minnesota he
got released from prison in 2014 he was
just getting his life together remember
that do you guys remember that media
depiction of saint george who was just
doing things for kids and just loved the
kids and really was trying to set a good
example and was just getting his life
together until i reminded people of what
his actual record was because it became
apparent to me that there was a reason
that they were not producing the police
footage because they wanted to make sure
that the lie was perpetuated around the
world and repeated over and over again
before we get into this she's talking
about the lying that he's not a martyr
for the cause but before we muddy the
waters and i can't remember how she
covers it they said mandela was a
terrorist winston churchill who was an
avid racist and said the death who is
they candace no no no they as in society
like how society perceives it because
basically what she's trying to do is
saying that because of the past he's not
a mark for the cause whether his past
was the past in terms of the cause of
what blm has done and has done
affirmative action and actually got rid
of say white privilege in some regard
jordan peterson would say there's no
right privilege but giving other people
opportunities they never would have had
regardless of who he was what he went to
achieve in terms of in his death and the
repercussions that he had
he was still a martyr for the course
even if he was a shitty person i don't
know he held a gun to a pregnant lady's
stomach but mahatma gandhi you know
gandhi the most peaceful man to ever
live look at i don't know a [ __ ] about
gandhi
i know who he is but like don't
don't you're gonna bring up these people
i'm like i don't
know he's an important person and like
indians love him and they say yeah
yeah so he used to like touch little
kids is he convicted um well and he
talks about in one of his uh writings
that he used to get his naked niece who
was like 14 at the time and he used to
test if he could stay celibate with her
sleeping next to him and he talks about
this he says he never did anything but
why are you getting your 14 year old
niece but he's like idolized as the most
important person and my point is it's
like really even though he did do some
great things yeah but he did some
terrible things but because
the british people they support his
ideas they're like oh my god he's so
amazing well i think i think the point
is like they were hiding there
yeah they hide that for gandhi though
they russia i'm not for hiding anything
is that mlk was killed by the us
government and they hid that like not a
lot of people unless you're from the us
most people outside the u.s don't
actually know so okay i know i've heard
that but i've also heard that that's a
conspiracy theory now if you could
google it literally you can find it the
the us cover yeah yeah okay the u.s
government i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm just saying i don't know yeah
mlk who killed his
his family believes that james earl was
framed but that's not the same thing as
oh did you notice it says it says who
killed mlk junior
his family believes let's see findings
if we're not filming from roma i don't
know i just i just that sounds like
something that's a conspiracy theory to
me
maybe i'm wrong i believe in a lot of
conspiracy theories
if i'm wrong i'm wrong
i just oh there we go u.s government
found guilty and conspiracy
assassinate. and this is from news one
so it's reputable she's not coming
because i swear i did read it no i'm not
okay yeah no i'm just thinking the
government has wrapped four weeks of
testimony okay and witnesses in the
civil trial was assassin dr king was
assassinated as the result of a
conspiracy the new york times reported
the king family who filed a civil suit
was awarded
a hundred dollars yeah i see
that's it so history is written by the
victims so like
did usa hear
they won't teach that in your curriculum
interesting the fact that you're from
the us you didn't even know and i'm sure
you studied oh but this is why it's
because it's uh over 70 we hold on 12
jurors and a swift um that dr king was
assassinated as a result of a conspiracy
the new york times at the time the king
family who filed the lost civil suit was
awarded a hundred dollars they donated
the
miniscule amount to charity lloyd lloyd
jones owner of jim's grill which was
close to blah blah claimed that the shot
which dr kim was fired from behind his
restaurant the local and state federal
government officials and the mafia were
all involved james earl ray who pleaded
guilty to assassinating king was renting
a room above the establishment was a
scapegoat the restaurant owner named
memphis police department earl king
as dr king's assassin according to a
press conference conference transcript a
claim that would be called into question
along other shocking details according
to the us justice department which
painstakingly attempts to dismantle
jower's
claims and mountains of evidence
presented at a memphis child jowers
insisted that a memphis pr
produce dealer which was involved in the
mafia gave jowers a hundred thousand
dollars to hire an assassin but i think
the reason is because it's a civil trial
and i i'm not yeah but i don't that when
it comes to that yeah that's hold on i
need to i don't want to
there's a civil case
yeah okay so
this is and i might be getting it wrong
but i think that's like outside of the
law like you're suing
and it's not like actually a legal trial
yeah it's it's similar to in the uk if
it's civil it's not like it's not
legally binding
but that's that's why they can't say
conclusively because it wasn't tried
like
in a court like it's not it's not
because they're like hiding it it's
because they haven't can like but the
fact that the u.s government are even
allowing and awarding them some
but it's not because it's not congress
but it's not the government it's a civil
right like that's that's the point all
right
and so i don't think it's like
they're hiding it it's that they didn't
prove it in court you know they proved
it in a civil trial i think i think you
could correct me if i'm wrong i might
get cooked in the comments i don't know
about that one they they always think
they got me too they always they always
want me to be smarter i'm like i'm sorry
i know about
relationships they're like why don't you
know your history i'm like look
i know certain things about history i
don't know everything before the truth
could get up from bed and put its shoes
on and here is the truth here is the
person whose life
and whose name is now synonymous with
justice nancy pelosi
george floyd has a rap sheet and i'm
going to remind you guys of it again
today he was arrested for delivery of a
controlled substance he was arrested and
put into jail he was arrested for theft
he was arrested for theft again he spent
10 months and 10 days in jail he was
arrested for failure to identify he
spent 15 days in jail you know it's
crazy when the media said that george
floyd died they painted him as like like
they they didn't have any of this in
there but when kevin samuels died they
all put in the title that like like man
that referred to him as like women as
leftovers like that was like the first
description they had of kevin samuels
and that's like a black guy who was like
doing stuff for his community
he was literally like trying to bring
black families back together in the u.s
and they paint him as the bad guy but
they put george floyd is like a martyr i
think that's her issue with it but with
a lot of social media a lot of it is
gynocentric it's very female-led yeah so
if you hurt someone's feelings it's
almost
painful
what about okay but he held a gun do a
pregnant wait is it
a gynocentric association look look yeah
was it the baby he actually killed a man
or whatever in context and some of them
were gang leaders but as soon as he came
and spoke out against the trans and and
the gay community they killed him but
when you they were actually talking
about uh
the baby the baby died no no no
okay so talking about shooting black
people and other marginalized groups is
fine but making a joke about gay people
which hurts their feelings now suddenly
that's weird doesn't it shouldn't
killing people and selling drugs to your
community be more harmful than hurting
someone's feelings you would you would
think
he was again arrested for possession of
a controlled substance less than one
gram of cocaine he was then arrested for
trespassing no forcible entry he was
arrested for delivery of a controlled
substance he was arrested for possession
with intent to manufacture or distribute
another 30 months in jail total he was
arrested for aggravate aggravated
robbery with a dangerous and deadly
weapon and that has really got to be the
most significant arrest for me because
of how sick what he did was ready here's
a statement really the only thing i see
bad in that is the aggravated robbery
because
if it's just drugs like a gram of drugs
like common man everyone does even suits
to do drugs
did she say robbery yeah i said
robbery's the only other ones too
are drugs and like over here
doing drugs is normal they even call
them nosebeasts i'm just saying like
it's not really that bad
there's men in suits you see
them okay i don't like those
i'm equal i don't like people doing
drugs i just it's not my thing i'm not
drug dealer i hate it i'm not do you
drink no i don't drink you don't drink
no i don't drink you've never seen me
drink out the show you're not muslim
what you're not no i just i think it's
stupid well if you go to dubai they'll
wife you up quickly but oh my god she
doesn't drink she's hella like you you
get a husband quick well yeah but there
aren't those the guys that are flying
like women
they live alive
you'll be the wife
don't be the poor party that gets shot
nice little trick nice little shake
you know i always say i'll mooch off of
my dab before i say it
dad
let me come home
the bells are tiring
let me move back in with you and mom
please